[Musique]
elle s'est assise en face de moi et elle
m'a dit
j'avais 9 ans quand il a fait éruption
dans la vie
il en avait 60 il était photographe
il m'a fait subir des attouchements et
il s'est servi de moi comme un pas
j'étais rabatteur pour amener à mon
bureau mes copines qui lui violait
il m'emmenait chercher mes copines
disait vouloir prendre des photos je
confirmer
en fait je les emmener à l'abattoir
il violait les petites filles et je ne
savais pas
jusqu'au jour où je suis entrée dans la
chambre et j'ai vu ma copine en train de
se faire violer par ce gros dégueulasse
je revois son regard à ce moment qui me
hante
tous les soirs
je dis bien tous les soirs je m'endors
avec ces visions d'horreur dans la tête
quand on m'a fait ma première siloscopie
pour mon endométriose on m'a dit que je
n'aurais pas d'enfant
et ça m'arrangeait bien parce que je me
sentais pas femme et je voulais surtout
pas être une femme
et pourtant j'ai aimé être enceinte cela
m'a redonné ma timidité
j'ai pu le dire et crever l'abcès à 44
ans
soit 35 ans après les faits
peut-être si on m'avait proposé une
écoute j'aurais pu le dire avant mais
personne ne m'a jamais posé la question
je viens de me raconter l'histoire d'une
patiente que j'ai appelé Charlie
ça fait 40 ans que je fais de la
gynécologie j'ai été comme vous sûrement
ébloui par les progrès faramineux de
cette médecine qui transplante des cœurs
qui grève des mains et qui réussit même
à faire des enfants sans rapport sexuel
et en même temps tellement dépité par
les problèmes qui restent sans solution
dans ma spécialité nombre d'infécondité
irrésolus malgré les outils
spectaculaires à notre disposition
je voulais agrandir ma vision de la
réalité et j'ai fait un master
d'histoire des sciences
j'ai compris que ceux qui avaient fait
avancer la connaissance avait souvent
fait un pas de côté
j'ai décidé de faire une thèse en
philosophie de la médecine intitulé
notre santé au risque de notre histoire
pour mettre en miroir les événements de
vie et les événements de santé
histoire de Charlie fut la première
ce jour a été un vrai basculement dans
mon exercice
imaginez j'avais suivi cette patiente
pendant 10 ans pour ce endométriose
sévère avant de savoir ce que je viens
de vous raconter
moi son médecin est-ce que je m'étais
posé les bonnes questions
et elle d'ailleurs m'en a posé une me
demandant si ce n'endométriose avait
avoir avec son histoire
peut-être vous en avez entendu parler
est-ce que vous savez ce qu'il endomètre
l'endomètre c'est un tissu qui
normalement
est à l'intérieur de l'utérus et qui
pour des raisons qu'on ignore dans ce
cas ces gars dans un autre organe la
vessie les intestins
alors est-ce que ce endométriose avait
avoir avec son histoire
ce jour j'ai fait un deal avec moi-même
je me suis dit cette teste tu vas la
faire
j'ai vu 300 patientes pour poser des
questions dont j'avais pas l'habitude
dans un entretien qui a duré deux ou
trois heures et ça a duré 5 ans
j'ai appris que Cassiopée que j'avais
suivi dans un long parcours de PMA
procréation médicalement assistée sans
succès
s'interdisait une grossesse c'était son
mot
elle voulait stopper sa ligne de femmes
alcoolique incapable d'élever les petits
terroriser à l'idée de reproduire la
maltraitance
j'ai appris par Kerguelen qui a un
moment de sa vie a fait une cystite
après chaque rapport qu'en fait c'est
cystite l'avait protégé
l'empêchant d'avoir des rapports dont
elle ne voulait plus
j'ai appris que remet atteinte d'une
polyarthrite avec été rongé c'est son
mot comme le sont les articulations dans
cette maladie par une culpabilité énorme
suite à la mort accidentelle de sa fille
de deux ans
écrasé sous ses yeux
la polyarthrite c'est une maladie
auto-immune le système immunitaire
normalement dressé à nous défendre se
retourne contre nous
et si nous étions le résultat de notre
histoire
et si nous étions des processus informés
dont l'information émotionnelle ne
pourrait pas être exclue
en tant qu'être de matière nous avons
une zone d'habitabilité physique en
dehors de laquelle on peut pas vivre
elle est limitée par la qualité de l'air
de l'eau la température les toxiques
tabac amiante pesticides
ma conviction et que nous avons
également une zone d'habitabilité
émotionnelle qui est bornée par des
émotions qui doivent rester supportables
nous avons un seuil de tolérance au-delà
duquel on peut pas vivre en bonne santé
ou pas vivre du tout
je m'explique
nos émotions sont un pont entre la
conscience et la matière elles ont
toutes un impact physique en rougi de
honte on palier de peur on tremble de
colère nos émotions sont nos amis elles
sont une information très précieuse sur
notre contact à l'environnement
mais elles peuvent devenir nos ennemis
si elles perdure avec intensité
d'où l'importance de cerner cette zone
d'habitabilité
ce qui est pas toujours facile parce que
nos émotions elles sont livrées en vrac
parce qu'elles peuvent être antagonistes
et puis parce qu'on nous apprend pas à
les reconnaître et quand elles sont
reconnues elles sont pas toujours les
bienvenus qui d'entre nous n'a pas
entendu un jour où il avait du chagrin
aller soit pas triste ou un jour où il y
avait peur mais n'est pas peur
alors que nos émotions elles sont
affamées de reconnaissance elles doivent
être accueillies reconnues et exprimés
on a le langage pour ceux mais pas que
la danse la musique l'écriture le sport
ce que vous voulez
si nos émotions ne sont pas reconnues ce
précieux message qu'elle transporte
devra trouver un autre canal pour être
entendu puisqu'il nous évite alors
corps qui prendra la relève parce que le
corps il sait tout de nous
alors une manifestera en fonction de sa
singularité son histoire s'aligner son
environnement par des signes banales du
petit colis dans le ventre ou une
maladie bénigne ou plus grave
ou mortel
parce que la vie n'est pas à n'importe
quel prix
après le viol qui la couvert de honte de
culpabilité de colère de haine Tina a
pris 20 kilos en quelques mois pour se
protéger c'est son mot se rendre moins
joli surtout pas désirable
comment vivre avec de telles émotions
qui nous étreignent le jour la nuit
pendant des mois des années des
décennies
mon hypothèse et que nos maladies elles
sont la manifestation de la sortie de
notre zone d'habitabilité physique les
toxiques on en a parlé et où émotionnel
ou de celles de notre lignée
nous héritons nos gènes de nos aïeux
cette transmission verticale elle est
fixée à la naissance
mais nous savons maintenant que
seulement 3% de nos gènes s'expriment
et c'est l'impact de l'environnement sur
les gènes appelés épigénétique qu'il les
pousse ou les empêche de s'exprimer
ce qui veut dire que
nous sommes pas ligotés dans nos bras
d'ADN
que notre santé elle est pas jouée
d'avance
si chacun d'entre nous intègre sa santé
dans son histoire si avec cette prise de
conscience et sa capacité d'action il en
devient acteur pour changer son
environnement ou seulement son rapport à
lui et réintégrer sa zone d'habitabilité
il a bien plus de chances de guérir que
s'il considère sa maladie comme une
malédiction sur laquelle il n'a aucune
prise
nous avons un champ du possible que nous
pouvons cultiver avec la connaissance de
nous-mêmes qui nous permettra dans un
premier temps de savoir ce qui ne nous
appartient pas pour que personne n'a
envie de dire mais alors mais si je suis
malade c'est de ma faute non non c'est
pas de notre faute si on a été en
contact avec l'amiante non c'est pas de
notre faute si notre père alcoolique a
mis de la violence dans toute la maison
qui a imprimé sur notre petit cœur
d'enfant la colère et de la peur qui
nous étreignent depuis des décennies
plus nous connaîtrons l'histoire de nos
aïeux mieux nous les comprendrons et moi
nous aurons d'émotions difficiles envers
eux
et puis cette connaissance de nous-mêmes
elle nous permettra de décoder le stress
en émotion bien identifié beaucoup plus
facile à apaiser
si on peut pas changer son passé on peut
changer les émotions inuites et une
émotion reconnue exprimée elle est déjà
apaisée
et puis on a les progrès de la
psychotromatologie qui nous ont permis
de comprendre la genèse et les
conséquences des émotions nées des
traumatismes par exemple la culpabilité
la honte la colère la peur la haine qui
est traigne parfois pendant des
décennies les victimes de violence
notamment sexuelles
on a aussi pour gérer nos émotions des
outils comme l'hypnose le mdr les TCC ou
d'autres psychothérapie
alors que les choses soient claires que
les choses soient très claires il est
pas question une seconde de nous priver
des progrès faramineux de la médecine
technologique celle qui s'occupent en
priorité de l'organe malade il est
question de la soutenir par la prise en
compte de notre versant émotionnel qui
est un paramètre incontournable de notre
réalité
mon travail m'a permis de comprendre que
nos maladies elles nous parlent de nous
notre histoire notre lignée et notre
environnement
il m'a permis de proposer ma réponse à
Charlie
a-t-elle été malade suite aux émotions
de honte et de culpabilité qu'ils l'ont
étreinte pendant des décennies
et peut-on même raisonnablement se poser
la question de savoir si ce n'est
endométriose aurait pu être prévenu par
la gestion précoce de ses émotions
cette souffrance dans la représentation
de la féminité je l'ai notée dans mes
200 dossiers d'endométriose
pour les deux tiers d'entre eux il y a
eu un traumatisme d'ordre sexuel
nous sommes en santé tant que nous
sommes en harmonie avec tous les champs
avec lesquels nous interagissons les
champs physiques on l'a vu et manteau
tant que nous restons à l'écoute de nos
émotions
la connaissance de nous-mêmes et de
notre zone d'habitabilité et à mon sens
une des clés du puzz la bonne santé pour
qu'on puisse tous mourir de vieillesse
je vous invite surtout vous qui êtes
jeunes à embrasser dans un même regard
votre santé et votre histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]